the fact that that happened so early did
that make like every day on set was like
a little tense like oh [ __ ]
i don't know i try not to think about it
that way in hindsight i'm like i guess i
was pretty like gripped a lot of times
but i tried to just relax and meet every
day is just like okay it's gonna be not
that bad i remember the end of jackass
three being where like ten like that the
final like couple weeks it was just like
ah like it was so much that was your
first sober one too yeah you're really
on edge right looking over your
shoulders yeah you know but like i was
super laid back on on the fourth one
like oh you know what am i gonna get in
the way of getting footage
right exactly the worst day i had
nothing even happened to me it was a it
was the same day we did it
yeah aaron's i did i the same day i pogo
sticks as nuts
in the morning jeff jermaine's like
we're gonna have this like the worst
stinging insect sing you in their lips
today i'm like okay and then like the
whole day i thought that up until
5 00 pm he i'm like when are we gonna do
that it's almost the end he's like oh i
didn't tell you that they couldn't find
the bug we're not doing that so the
whole day i literally was getting we
were in this like weird hilly out in
like the malibu hills out there i was
gonna run to the road and hitchhike out
of there that's how freaked out i was i
keep making this plan i'm like i'll just
run out there i'll put my thumb out i'll
say just take me anywhere and i'll get
an uber once i can get a signal and i'll
never i'll just tell them the next day
i'm sorry yeah because i remember went
to the we went to the hilton to do a the
podcast with danger and then i was in
the lobby and then preston walked down
and he like looked at me he's like
what are you doing here why are you here
and like he was like freaked out that
why would i be there and he thought like
it was some elaborate scheme to get him
like that's how traumatized he was yeah
well and the anticipation too like
that's what knoxville was saying like
for something like a ball stunt he's
like just make it so when i get there we
shoot it right away i don't want to be
standing there worried about it thinking
about it like yeah knoxville did look
like
uncharacteristically concerned before
that bullet hit whereas in the past he
actually looked forward to it like and
he'd be cracking jokes the whole time he
wasn't he was he was yeah you could see
him thinking about it it was tough man
it was tough and i remembered when we
were filming jackass number two
he uh
there was some like hot potato bit with
uh
uh oh the little guy from
gay guy from sex in the city
yes that's what they call them i didn't
just make that up they called them
there's like a hot potato bit with the
stun gun and knoxville just didn't like
it he's like i don't he's he's like dude
i don't like electricity balls i and i
can't wait to get in front of the next
bullet i just don't
and i thought like oh okay come on you
know but then sure enough he gets to the
bullring and he's just yeah
great mood and
like i don't get it the time i think the
opener for jackass too he was inside the
house and he did it like three or four
times where a whole stampede of him
would come through and just
and he there was like a
this high of a window bottom that it
would just hit him in the legs and then
they'd yeah
yeah said it again again again and each
time it looked like he died i just how
do you go yeah i need to do that again
like right you narrowly escape death all
these heavy bowls of wood you know
over a thousand pounds right some of
those things
how does he not get completely broken up
i mean he did but yeah i i have no idea
the brain bleeding the concussion and
the [ __ ] my only guess is that
growing up in knoxville tennessee
that
there's like
you know rodeo is a thing yeah and like
the like the definition of like
manliness is riding bulls being in the
ring with bulls and so it's not so
that's like the highest
standard of manliness and so like he
just
put so much equity like so much
value in that and that's what he wants
like that's his highest goal
it's also great footage whereas like
electrocution
right it's always like
you don't even hear like you have to put
in a sound effect for the people that
know that it even happened like it's
less of a visual so i get also why did
not like what's the point of the
electrocution it sucks and it's not
great footage it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude